It didn't take long, but Pokemon Go has became
a global sensation only days after it was
released. Fans are wild for the augmented-reality
game, which sends Pokemon trainers out into
their neighborhoods and communities on a quest
to catch 'em all.
(intense Pokemon guy singing)
And naturally, the massive popularity of the
app means we've already learned plenty of
tips and tricks. Here's a list of what all
you trainers should watch out for as you play...as
well as a few real-life issues that trainers
have encountered along the way.
Don't Waste Your Stuff
The first lesson we learned when playing Pokémon
Go is that timed consumables run on real time,
not in-game time. If you use one of these
items and the game crashes for an hour, you'll
log back in to find your buff already expired.
Don't use an Incense, Lure Module, or Lucky
Egg unless you have thirty minutes available
to make the most of it.
Don't Trespass
Game developer Niantic isn't new to the augmented-reality
game. In their previous release, Ingress,
users visit and claim local points of interest
for their team. Niantic re-used these same
points of interest when developing the locations
for Pokémon Go. So be smart! Don't risk the
wrath of property owners or authorities by
trying to reach these same locations in Pokémon
Go.
"Hey you! Get offa my property! Now!"
(blam)
Don't Miss the Intel
One major drawback of Pokémon Go is the lack
of a mapping tool. Some unofficial maps have
sprung up, but none are as complete or as
easy to use as the official map made for Ingress.
As we mentioned before, Niantic recycled its
Ingress portal locations for Pokémon Go.
So do yourself a favor: download the game
and sign up for an account. Even if you don't
plan on playing, you can use the Ingress online
intel tool to easily find your nearest portals,
which are also Gyms or Pokéstops.
"Again I would like you all to come in, to
my Poke Stop restaurants, here in Mililani
Mauka as well as my Waipahu location. So thank
you very much, hope to see you at my Poke
Stop restaurants."
And if you wind up at this dude's fish restaurant
in Hawaii, you've walked too far. Better check
that map again...
Don't catch and drive
This should be obvious, but don't swipe away
with your Pokeball in the car. While you can
technically catch wild Pokemon at any speed,
is it really worth the risk?
(crash)
You should only be driving to get to your
location, then get out and get some exercise.
That's the point of the entire game, after
all.
Well, that, and for Nintendo to earn a bunch
of money after the Wii U flopped.
Ditch those extra Pidgeys
If you play enough, you'll probably have a
lot of extra Pidgeys or other low-level Pokemons
knocking around. Did you know that you can
exchange them for something better?
"Pika?"
If you transfer a Pokemon to Professor Willow,
he'll give you one species-specific candy
in exchange. You'll also get three candies
every time you catch a new Pokemon. And because
you use candies to power-up and evolve your
Pokemon, you can catch and transfer 19 Pidgeys
and have enough candy to evolve the twentieth
one all the way to Pidgeot.
Of course, when we eat that much candy, we
don't evolve into anything. We just do this:
(Bart Simpson going crazy)
Don't Evolve Without a Lucky Egg
Speaking of evolution, you should always have
a Lucky Egg active before you evolve a Pokemon.
Lucky Eggs are different from regular eggs,
and don't require an incubator. They give
double XP for 30 minutes. Ideally, you'll
want to have enough candy on hand to evolve
several Pokémon in a row. Go to your items
menu and select a Lucky Egg, then tap it on
your screen to activate it. Next, start evolving!
Of course when we eat lucky eggs, we don't
get any extra XP. We just do this:
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to share
your tips for Pokemon Go...